previously a man had to be a
contributing member of the society and
he had to have a good job and he had to
ask for your father's hand in marriage
remembering that a lot of the time sex
was held until you had you'd been wed so
you're not just talking about waiting
seven days until ovulation's over you're
talking about waiting an entire six
months or perhaps a year and then you
gotta ask for the father's hand in
marriage and you've got to have the
Dowry and you've got to do the
organization all this stuff if you wait
that long men will meet that criteria
like men will do what is asking of them
in order to get sex and not much more
if the price and the uh the the
requested price for sex is all of these
things making sure that you are somebody
that is contributing and has a good job
and all that they'll do it but if it's
being the right place at the right time
at the end of the night in a nightclub
they'll also do that this isn't for me
to say women are causing men to be the
lay about useless people that we know
that they can be it's just me saying
that there is an interesting ethical
question to ask about if more and more
women have sex with men who they would
not get into a relationship with
that encourages men to not be
relationship worthy in order to get sex
sex is something that drives men to be a
type of person worthy of sex and if the
price of sex is incredibly low they'll
meet that price
right now it's difficult for women to
find a man that they're attracted to and
for men to find a woman that is
attracted to them right you have an ever
increasing group of high performing
women that are two women for every one
man completing a four-year U.S college
degree by 2030 women earn on average 111
pounds more than men do between the ages
of 21 and 29 what you have is a ever
increasing cohort of very high
performing women fantastic women's
Liberation Movement we needed to have
parity when it comes to Opportunities
For Education and employment
a problem that arises is that women
fundamentally want to be in a
relationship with a man who is better
educated with more money than them this
is on average not every woman but if you
were to ask women how much do you value
your partner's employment and
educational outcomes they would say
greater than a man no man is going to
turn down a 10 out of 10 physical woman
because she's unemployed however there
are many women who would turn down a 10
out of 10 physical man because he is a
layup out on the couch okay so the issue
you have is there's this ever increasing
cohort of high performing women but
there are never decreasing cohort of
ultra high performing men that are up
and across from them so you could call
this the tall girl problem right
everybody has a tall girlfriend if
you're a six foot one woman without
heels you're looking at professional
athletes because on average most women
want to date men that is as tall or
taller than them you could see this
basically being the same when it comes
to employment and education most women
on average want to date a man who is as
educated and as employed as they are or
more
if you have an Ever decreasing group of
ultra high performing men this means
that they have a huge opportunity to
just chew through this entire Market
here they can they have a wealth of
options so they don't need to settle
down because there is a constant
conveyor belt of women going after them
the stats on Tinder bear this out that
the bottom 80 percent of men are
competing for the bottom 20 of women on
Tinder and the top 80 percent of women
are competing for the top 20 of men so
this means that most men to most women
are effectively invisible and most women
to a small number of men are effectively
usable I I definitely am very curious
about this whole idea around uh you know
mating and how women essentially like
mate up later like laterally and up and
men are laterally and down and so I'm
like and the more successful the more
status the more intelligence a woman has
the less likely she is to be in a
relationship to stay married
I'm I'm [ __ ] so I really am curious
about this scenario yeah uh again I I
don't mean to try and put a downer on
how achieving women there's no reason
that they should hold themselves back
from doing this but it is there is a
difficult situation you've got going on
here it's hard for men to raise
themselves up because it seems like
women outperform men in education and
employment when they have the breaks
taken off the only reason that we seem
to have male superiority in the past is
because women had the breaks put on them
if you look at education outcomes in
school women outperform boys that
straight up outperform boys there are
some subjects in which boys outperform
girls but for the most part they don't
you could argue that that's due to the
way that assessment is done that we
should look at trying to have schooling
done in a different way it should be
more active and so on and so forth but
there are huge problems right like girls
just straight up outperform boys that
means that education outcomes are going
to be difficult to bring back down
without them putting the brakes back on
women but you can't get around the fact
that on average women want to date a man
who's more educated than they are the
same thing goes for employment
especially when you consider the
educational outcomes open the door to
employment opportunities right exactly
so what needs to change to make it work
is it a male perception thing
or is it yeah the problem that you have
here and I don't like I'm trying
not to sort of lay the blame at the feet
of women the issue that you have is that
women are The Gatekeepers to sex yeah
and what that means is that it's women
who ultimately choose the men men don't
choose the woman on average now yes
there are there are some issues that you
have amongst for men generally that the
number of men reporting No Sex in the
last year has tripled so if you see a
man on the street
pointing at them one in three of them
hasn't had sex in the last year that
study finished in 2018 before the
pandemic it honestly wouldn't surprise
me if one in two if half of the men that
you see on the street under the age of
30 haven't had sex in the last year so
you go well that's not very good but
it's not great for women either like
women here in this situation also need
Partners in a monogamous Society it's
one to one right so if you don't have
good quality well
viable men in women's eyes that means
that women don't have viable partners
for themselves and this leads to stories
about like where all the good men at
like R female dating strategy subreddits
come about and stuff like that
I don't think that it's particularly
good for women either in terms of what's
driving it you have this change in terms
of the power dynamic between men and
women uh the ability to get status
resources and employment and this has
started to switch another element is a
globalized sexual Marketplace that
previously uh if you were a woman you
would or if you were a guy you would be
competing with the other men for this
particular pool of women
within your village you know there was
maybe 300 eligible people and 150 of
them were guys in 150 of them were girls
but as soon as you globalize the sexual
Marketplace any girl with an Instagram
account is now fair game for any guy
with an Instagram account so you open up
this sexual Marketplace which further
means that those turbo Chads at the top
the absolute super performing guys that
are the eight out of tens nine out of
tens ten out of 10 guys they can further
capitalize on their High status
employment and education because they
can access not only within their
geographical area but they can access
the entire world that also means the
women who are quite rightly they see
this high value man who is going to
speak to them why wouldn't you accept
his advances or at least his message and
start talking to him the problem with
this situation when you add in the fact
that sex has become decoupled from
having emotions and that the sexual
Revolution meant that people didn't need
to wait till they get into a
relationship or to be married in order
to have sex
is that some men will sleep with some
women without having any intention of
getting into a relationship with them
right after that that can create a
skewed perception of mate value in the
women that suggests well hang on I got
this turbochad 10 out of 10 guy before
for one night a couple of months ago I
need to hold on until the same value man
comes along again so that I can get into
a relationship with him that's a failure
of cross-sex mind reading in that they
didn't realize this guy was prepared to
have sex with them but wasn't
necessarily prepared to get into a
relationship with them so the whole sort
of milieu that you end up with with this
mating crisis is a bunch of resentful
men right at the bottom uh they are
retreating from society they're watching
more porn than ever they're playing more
video games than ever you have a large
cohort of women who have been scorned by
moderate value and high value men
they're resentful of men generally they
Retreat into careers they work at jobs
they don't like to buy shoes they don't
need to impress people they don't care
about they commit themselves to a life
of Korea not that that's something which
should be bad financial Independence is
really important however
a lot of the time you just need to read
the articles on the internet to see that
that's done with resentment rather than
with love it's done as like a middle
finger to the patriarchy rather than I
genuinely want this and then you have
this group of guys at the very very top
and all that they're doing is just cap
like completely uh conquering and
capitalizing all of the opportunity that
they get from these women I don't think
that it's particularly good for anybody
and uh that is the problem that we've
got with the current Dynamics in The
Mating Market I'm wondering if there's a
sincerity to all that and I'm wondering
if a man really is okay with a
attractive 10 out of 10 woman that
doesn't have
a lot of success or drive and or
intelligence perhaps like what does a
man actually want
it's a good question
um
the data definitely suggests that men
are less concerned with uh employment
and education prospects amongst women
certainly less so comparably than women
one of the imbalances in that women
often date up and across in terms of uh
status and resources and education men
often date across and down in terms of
age and no one really wants to point the
finger at men and say have you ever
considered just dating like four years
older because
I'm 40. I get it I agree
[Music]